J'ai lu votre dossier,
vous êtes une jeune femme très troublée,
croyez-le ou non, je suis ici pour vous aider,
vous savez, lorsque vous mettez votre main par
la fenêtre d'une voiture en mouvement, vous pouvez sentir
l'air et le guider, je peux pousser le  de l'air
ensemble de l'eau à d'autres trucs vous
pensiez que vous étiez hors de certains je peux
vous apprendre ce mec merci de nous avoir rencontrés
bien sûr je comprends que vous avez des
inquiétudes à propos de votre fils
Andy et moi avons toujours été très proches
mais nous pensons qu'il est  intimidé et
regarde qui est là
donc c'est très bon moment ma stupide terre
folle
peut-être que je me soucie d'Andrew et Lauren
conscients qu'il y a eu un petit
incident à l'école pour les voir partir j'ai
besoin que tu ailles le chercher pour moi ils
ne le sont pas  aller n'importe où
nous devons assurer la sécurité de la
communauté qu'est-ce qui est si
pur à propos des mutins ce sont mes
enfants tu dois les aider
je ne m'ai pas dit que son pouvoir papa met les
gens comme en prison mon expérience les choses ont
changé c'est ton propre enfant il y a
rien de plus important pour moi que ma
famille  les x-men la Confrérie on
ne sait même plus s'ils existent plus
je vous propose de réfléchir à ce qu'il y a de mieux
pour votre famille on fait quoi ça va
aller descendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements
] c'est un fardeau oui mais alors  Je suppose que
[Musique]
parle-moi de Lorna les informations que j'ai
sont les tiennes bien ma famille est en sécurité
toi